et son nom botanique est Eichhornia crassipes.
Étonnamment, au Nigeria, la plante est connue sous d'autres noms,
des noms associés à des événements historiques,
ainsi que des mythes.
Dans certaines régions, la plante est appelée Babangida.
Quand vous entendez Babangida, ça vous rappelle les forces militaires
et ses coups d'état,
et vous pensez à la peur, la restriction.
Dans les régions du Nigeria du delta du Niger,
la plante est également appelée Abiola.
Quand vous entendez Abiola, ça vous rappelle des élections annulées
et vous pensez : espoirs déçus.
Dans le sud-ouest du Nigeria,
la plante est connue sous Gbe'borun.
Gbe'borun est une phrase du Yoruba
que l'on peut traduire par « rumeurs » ou « rapporteur ».
Quand vous pensez aux rumeurs, vous pensez : reproduction rapide, destruction.
Et dans les régions du Nigeria où on parle Igala,
la plante est connue sous A Kp'iye Kp'oma,
Et quand vous l'entendez, vous pensez à la mort.
On peut le traduire littéralement à « mort à la mère et à l'enfant ».
J'ai personnellement été en contact avec cette plante en 2009.
C'était peu après mon transfert des Etats-Unis vers le Nigeria.
J'ai quitté mon travail dans une grosse société américaine
et j'ai décidé de faire acte de foi,
un acte de foi qui provient d'une conviction profonde
qu'il y avait beaucoup de travail à faire au Nigeria
dans le domaine du développement durable.
Et moi voilà en 2009,
plus précisément, fin 2009,
à Lagos sur un pont.
J'ai regardé sur ma gauche et j'ai vu cette image saisissante.
C'étais une image de bateaux de pêche
qui étaient cernés par des tapis denses de jacinthes d'eau.
Et j'étais vraiment peinée de ce que je voyais
parce que je me disait :
« Ces pauvres pêcheurs,
comment vont-ils poursuivre leurs activités quotidiennes
avec ces restrictions. »
Et puis je me suis dit : « Il doit y avoir une meilleure solution. »
Une solution gagnant-gagnant où l'environnement serait préservé
en éliminant cette herbe
puis en la transformant en un avantage économique
pour les communautés dont les vies sont les plus impactées
par l'invasion de cette herbe.
Ceci, je dirais, était mon Eurêka.
Et donc j'ai fait d'autres recherches pour en savoir plus
sur les usages bénéfiques de cette herbe.
D'entre tous, l'un m'a le plus interpellée.
C'était l'utilisation de la plante pour l'artisanat.
Et je me suis dit : « Quelle merveilleuse idée. »
Personnellement, j'adore l'artisanat,
surtout l'artisanat tissé autour d'une histoire.
Et alors j'ai pensé : « Ceci pourrait facilement être déployé
dans des communautés
sans compétences techniques. »
Puis je me suis dit : « Trois étapes simples pour une méga solution. »
Première étape : aller dans les cours d'eau récolter les jacinthes d'eau.
Comme ça, vous créez une route d'accès.
Deuxièmement, vous desséchez les tiges des jacinthes d'eau.
Et troisièmement, tissez les jacinthes et transformez-les en produits.
La troisième étape était un défi.
Vous voyez, j'ai une formation d'informaticien
et donc pas issue des arts créatifs.
Et donc, j'ai commencé ma recherche
pour savoir comment je pouvais apprendre à tisser.
Cette recherche m'a amenée à une communauté à Ibadan, où je vivais,
nommé Sabo.
Sabo veut dire « le quartier des étrangers ».
Et la communauté est principalement constituée de gens
du nord du pays.
Donc, j'ai littéralement pris mes herbes séchées à la main,
il y en avait beaucoup plus,
et j'ai frappé à chaque porte pour trouver qui pouvait m'apprendre
comment tisser les tiges des jacinthes en cordes.
On m'a dirigée vers la cabane de Malam Yahaya.
Cependant, le problème était que Malam Yahaya ne parlait pas anglais
et je ne parlais pas Hausa.
Mais de jeunes enfants sont venus au secours
et ont aidé à traduire.
Et c'est ainsi que j'ai commencé mon parcours pour apprendre à tisser
et à transformer ces tiges séchées
en de longues cordes.
Avec mes longues cordes en main,
j'étais alors prête à fabriquer mes produits.
C'était le début de partenariats.
Travaillant avec des fabricants de paniers en rotin pour créer des produits.
Donc avec ceci en poche, je me sentais confiante
de pouvoir importer ce savoir
aux communautés fluviales
et les aider à transformer leur malheur en prospérité.
En prenant ces herbes et en les tissant
en produits qui pouvaient être vendus.
On a des stylos, de la vaisselle,
des sacs à mains, et des boites à mouchoirs.
Ainsi, aider les communautés
à considérer les jacinthes d'eau sous un angle différent.
Regarder la jacinthe d'eau comme précieuse,
esthétique, durable, robuste et résiliente.
Changement de noms, changement de moyens de subsistance.
De Gbe'borun, rumeurs,
à Olusotan, conteur.
Et de A Kp'iye Kp'oma, qui est « mort à la mère et à l'enfant »,
à Ya Du J'ewn W'lye Kp'Oma,
« fournisseur de nourriture à mère et enfant ».
J'aimerais terminer par une citation de Michael Margolis.
Il a dit : « Si vous voulez apprendre plus sur une culture, écoutez les histoires.
et si vous voulez changer une culture, changez les histoires. »
Et donc, de la communauté de Makoko, à Abobiri, à Ewoi,
en passant par Kolo et à Owahwa, Esaba,
nous avons changé l'histoire.
Merci pour votre écoute.
(Applaudissements)